hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to feed us the horrifying
game about horrifying piranhas that won
a horrifyingly suckle the blood out of
your juice bags also known is your meat
they don't want to suck your blood they
want to eat the meat off of the bones
they're gonna shred your flesh then get
the I don't know Bloods do says enough
let me try this again hi welcome to feed
us a cool game that I lied to play lie
like blue F Hodge what sorry I god
dammit I am no mess so now that I've
spilled water all over myself
hello hi I'm markiplier I play video
games on YouTube for a living it's cool
job now I'm playing this one so I don't
know what to do with my hands anymore
let's play the damn game already because
that's what you're here for
anyway why I don't need to know about
increasing the number of piranhas thank
you now we're gonna go so this is one of
my favorite games from a while back I
used to play a lot of flash games and
this one's super fun you can play it for
yourself for free in the link in the
description my god this is the longest
intro ever let's just get to the damn
game okay
so we're gonna play this it's called
feed us your a piranha
you gotta collect blood to buy up great
you can see how I tried to say this in a
in a more efficient way in the beginning
of this but it just didn't come through
correctly so happy
take that lady this is what you get for
having fun on a kayak so now that you've
oh god I forgot oh my god I forgot how
horrible it was well there you go
everybody lag and everything so that's
what you do isn't this a fun game isn't
this a good reason for me to have fun
playing a game oh my god it's like
revealing so many things about my psyche
so anyway so now that you have Ludd you
upgrade your fish spine hit boats harder
that sounds good but I don't know
enough so I'm gonna get another piranha
oh wait no bang huh yeah there we go so
now I have a piranha buddy to help me go
fetch more blood so do you get it did
you get the game okay
so anyway jump up to knock down humans I
get that I know that I know what I'm
supposed to do so this game actually is
a lot of fun that doesn't look like a
fun time excuse me I didn't know there
were three of you on there ah oh they
all look so concerned now they look
concerned hey where you think you're
going there sorry about all the lag hang
on wait oh my god it's why is it so
laggy hello welcome back it crashed I
just I messed up I was having other
things running the you don't care at all
time to get back to the game oh boy so
this is feed us it's game the piranhas
we're gonna play hi hello hi how's it
going
sorry uh we need your blood do you mind
do you mind just a little do you kitty
are you are you all right there with
your face all missing okay bye you have
a good day now oh noes is she fat or
just pregnant I don't know Oh No I
almost wanted to say I hope she's just
fat that would've been very offensive
never mind forget I'm saying anything oh
I shouldn't post this video on the
Internet
ah it's the nightmare scenario it's
literally the name they're all as
Leslie's despise everything's going
horribly wrong haha anyway play this
game for yourself I'm gonna upgrade my
jaws so I can eat fat friend I'm the bit
meaner now oh oh no oh no now I can
recover it I think I can recover it how
do I recover it how do I recover from
this I can do it eventually
screw your paddleboat oh my god who'd
have thought it was piranhas
yeah Babette Jabbar come here you white
whoa hey whoa whoa whoa wait no no no
not allowed wait
something bets wait huh huh boy Oh God
Oh God it's irrecoverable lady why why
is this happened why is this happening
to me I was just trying to show these
gossip people a cool game ah okay we're
back
welcome everybody to the feed us let's
play let's try this once more
hello everybody my name is seananners
and welcome to let's play feed us I'm
gonna play and show you what it's all
about
you're a piranha and you got to recruit
more piranhas buddies and upgrade your
fur on a body by getting blood and where
do you get blood from the locals in the
ocean oh look it's a happy family in a
canoe well that guy certainly isn't
pregnant so it must have just been a
beer belly before good ol beer belly so
what we've learned is that everything
can be horrible but everything can come
together so long as you just believe and
now I believe I'm gonna win this game
and get all the blood I need to upgrade
everything I've ever wanted in my life
yay 5.4 liters of blood that's awesome
that's really gonna help me when I want
to upgrade my piranhas hmm I think I'll
go for the jaws upgrade huh look more
teeth
hahahahahaha now I'm able to bite bodies
faster and harvest more blood
look I've even unlocked the next level
and I should watch out for those pesky
sharks cuz they bite and they bite me
now
them hey wait whoa hey whoa think you're
doing that you here buddy urban DRB oh
yeah bird er be your buddy urban whoa
are you reenacting the Titanic there yep
whoo oh come on now now now don't it da
no no no it's better it's better down
where it's better but wetter take it
from me under the sea hey oh boy
oh hey ah there we go that's what I was
looking for that's what I was hoping for
Wow 35 pounds holy crap I never did oh
oh hey whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa hey
no no I need more upgrades that's what I
need okay so you can see why this game
is fun it's kind of a classic grow and
upgrade style thing with a little twist
in that it's horribly violent you gotta
eat to survive well not even just sir uh
you got prettier didn't ya yeah sure did
yeah you you you whatever you are cuz
I'm pretty sure you're not a piranha
anymore oh boy I got more friends I'm an
Abba nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom
epic combo where'd she go just the one
you having a good day up not anymore
little blue haven't I hey hey hey are
you one of his own I hope you miss me
douche nozzle how about yes boink I've
turned into a young punk rocker this is
what young punk rockers look like right
have an Abba Dabba I'm biting you have
an Abba Dabba I'm a freaking fish have
an Abba Dabba look at me go popping it
up bap bap bap murder dragon a key hmm
no terrible under bugging out but you
like me don't make fun of me
welcome value you desk going oh no i
acne oh god go oh not gonna look at me
I'm so hideously ugly
I got a premium ruin sorry about the
spit oh no no
No whoa no miss me
whoa no oh no bang okay I am bonk
whoa no I got my under my fix I messed
it up with an overbite as well you're my
prayer now uh yes yeah
y'all the ladies are gonna respect me as
a person what am i doing I don't know I
don't know what to do what are you doing
bonk
happy vacation instantly wound Rand Rand
Wow
and honk honk oh no friend
everything got Brende 19.9 206 noms cuz
that's pirate piranhas are cute
pirates are cute too is what I was gonna
say but they nom up a storm an aren't
they adorable
I should've grabbed my Benz ha oh oh no
I'm not like finding Nemo
besides I squirted out a bunch of seeds
don't look at me like that like Free
Willy except death lots and lots of -
freeway hey whoa hey whoa hey whoa eh
whoa hey whoa hey whoa hey whoa hey whoa
I'm a fish I'm a fish urine out of fish
you're a shark [ __ ] you [ __ ] you I'm off
fishy fishy foo I look at me off is she
a fishy
[ __ ] you I think I did it yeah my finals
uh sorry I got a haircut I needed to get
a job Hey Hey I finally got braces wait
tink huh wait pygmy you pressed I would
be sorry sorry again sorry about all
this sorry for the trouble of death
sorry for the death trouble sorry for
the problems
hey we want old nuke oh no he got Jeremy
I never liked him anyway grouper jumping
your boot by the finish [ __ ] [ __ ]
rubadoux boot by the [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh good more sharks no humans
boo-boo-boo-boo-boo-boo-boop damn sharks
your boy
I love you anyway one look at me fish
who are fish so good fishy fish no I got
eat it oh but I did what did I do it it
there we go I might have done it that
might had done it that might have done
it that might have got me would I needed
I'm a big fishy fishy
mutton what whoa want to Casino proper
oh no you got Jimmy
oh no I'm Josh dad oh oh I thought I was
gonna go right in front of his face
there we go that's enough right good yay
oh that's it oh okay that's all we get
for celebration
okay so that was feed us as crappy as
this game started out or this let's play
this game was fine this is the guy was
doing wrong this game is very fun and
there's multiple games in this series
you can check them all out through the
link in the description below thank you
everybody so much for watching I've been
playing a few flash games lately it
reminds me how much I actually love to
play flash games so if you got any games
that you want me to see played did it
did in the future let me know in the
comments or send me somewhere Twitter I
don't know something get it to me
somehow so thanks again everybody and as
always I will see you in the next video
but I turn crop this trial is a trial
that will pierce your heart who the hell
do you think
did I killed everyone on that plane now
it's good right